je m'appelle benjamin pannetier et je
suis étudiant
si agroparistech et si je suis ici ce
soir c'est pour vous parler de la
pollution microplastiques j'aimerais
pour cela revivre avec vous une journée
banale que j'ai pu vivre il y a un an
jour pour jour nous étions mercredi et
comme nombre d'étudiants et si même dans
cette salle je me suis levé en retard
dans la précipitation j'ai pris les
vêtements qui me tombait sous la main je
me suis brosser les dents rapidement et
hop
j'étais déjà dans la voiture avec mon
coloc et d'autres covoitureurs sur l'a6
direction massy ou le premier td de la
journée avait déjà commencé la journée
suivi son cours et nous sommes rentrés
en passant par le supermarché du coin
pour acheter des gâteaux et des pâtes
bon marché base notable de la
gastronomie étudiante
une fois n'est pas coutume ce soir leur
a entrepris même de faire une lessive
bref une journée banale sans
consommation de plastique à première vue
enfin il y avait dans les courses mais
où on avait mis en place dans notre
colocation un système de recyclage
compenser efficace alors aucun problème
plus tard dans la soirée
je suis tombé sur une vidéo qui m'a
réellement choqués la scène se déroule
au pérou où l'on voit un camion
déversant dans le fleuve amazone
l'ensemble des détritus qui transportent
j'étais découragée de constater que mes
quelques efforts pour diminuer la
consommation de plastique étaient
réduits à néant par de telles actions
à côté de ça moi j'avais l'impression
d'avoir un impact négligeable voire
neutre alors j'ai décidé que je voulais
en faire plus je voulais comprendre et
participer à la réflexion pour résoudre
cette proposition plastique c'est ainsi
que quelques semaines plus tard je
rejoignais l'association siplast x pour
faire court c'est une association
étudiante qui s'intéressent à la
pollution microplastiques par le prisme
de la science et la sensibilisation
elle agit en mer méditerranée où est
elle liée organise chaque année une
expédition à la voile en y appliquant
j'ai compris que cette pollution était
problématique était une problématique
complexe aux multiples sources et que
tout un chacun était impliqué avec le
recul je peux affirmer que lors de ma
journée pourtant si banal j'avais
participé sans le savoir au problème de
la pollution plastique et émis des
microplastiques revenons d'abord sur ce
qu'est le plastique c'est un ensemble de
matériaux basé sur le un polymère c'est
à dire une longue molécule formé de
briques alimentaires auxquels on ajoute
des additifs pour rajouter des
propriétés intéressantes comme de la
couleur ou la résistance à la chaleur
les plastiques sont présents sous toutes
les formes mais voudrait montrer un
reportage de 1970 pour montrer à quel
point le plastique nous entoure et à
quel point il est fantastique et était à
cette époque là promet tâtonner regarder
ce qui se passerait si on avait plus les
matières plastiques
toutes ces qualités font que c'est
maintenant un matériau noble dont
l'industrie est en plein essor
ainsi le tonnage produit double tous les
cinq ans et en europe
on fabrique chaque année 8 millions de
tonnes de matières plastiques soit dix
fois plus que d'aluminium
le résultat est que les matières
plastiques ont maintenant leur salon
mais quels sont les domaines de leur
emploi les matières plastiques se sont
d'abord développé dans le vêtement un
autre secteur qui est un développement
très rapide le secteur de l'emballage le
plastique a envahi notre univers à telle
enseigne qu'on pourrait parler de
l'avènement d'un âge du plastique
après celui du fer bon vous avez
j'espère apprécié ce court extrait de ce
reportage typique des années 70 et
j'espère d'ailleurs qu'il vous a pas
trop endormi donc pour ça j'aimerais
faire un test un petit test pour vous
réveiller qui dans la salle aux ray
maintenant affirmer qu'il se situe à
plus de 50 cm de quelconques matières
plastiques vous pouvez le jeune amant en
ce qu'ils pensent de façon je vois rien
donc bon bon bah je suppose et que vous
avez tous raison puisque je n'ai pas vu
de bras levés et en effet dans le tee
shirt de votre voisin il y a cinq pour
cent des la stade qui est un dérivé du
polyuréthane c'est à dire c'est une
matière plastique là dans le pc qui est
juste là la coque est faite en
polycarbonate un autre plastique et les
gourmands qui cache des gâteaux dans
leur sac
sachez que c'est grâce au polyéthylène
que votre en cas reste croustillant
toute la journée
vous voyez on ne peut pas y échapper
c'est un il n'y a pas un seul domaine
qui échappent qui fait faux bond
agroalimentaire textile automobile
construction distribution tous les
secteurs consomme une énorme quantité de
plastique puisque ce sont des matériaux
très peu cher très léger et adaptable à
toutes les utilisations dans
documentaire que vous avez entendu on
nous dit qu'en 1970 il y avait huit
millions de tonnes de produits en europe
aujourd'hui regardez où l'on en ait plus
de 350 millions de tonnes sont produites
dans le monde annuellement et parmi
elles 40 % sont destinés à un usage
unique
le problème c'est que ce qui fait le
plus grand atout des matériaux
classiques c'est-à-dire leur robustesse
leur résistance à l'eau en fait
également
or plus grand point faible lorsqu'il
s'agit de la fin de vie de ses produits
ces polymères complètement artificielles
sont apparus très récemment par rapport
à l'apparition de la vie
il n'existe donc pas d'enzymes produite
par des organismes marins capables de
dégrader ces matériaux dans des
conditions naturelles
nous avons donc créé inconsciemment un
cocktail parfait pour une pollution
majeure
alors d'abord il suffit d'ajouter une
production mondiale énorme pour un
matériau ensuite que ce matériau soi
très résistant et enfin pousser un mode
de consommation aux états unis qui
favorisant des mauvaises gestions et
alors qu'on ne sait toujours pas traiter
certaines formes de plastique ainsi la
pollution océanique qui atteint nos
océans chaque année est estimée entre 8
et 12 millions de tonnes dans le monde
je pense que beaucoup d'entre vous
connaissent déjà ce problème
on a tous entendu parler des continent
de plastique dans les océans dans
l'imaginaire collectif et dans
l'illustration qu'en fait la presse ce
sont des véritables décharge flottante
sur lesquels il serait quasiment
impossible de marcher moi même je vais
même imaginer ça comme ça avant en fait
c'est une image très sensationnaliste
puisque dans la littérature scientifique
les continents ce plastique et ne pèse
que quelques kilos par kilomètre carré
alors imaginé dix kilos sur une surface
grande comme le 5e arrondissement où
nous sommes c'est pas ce que j'appelle
un continent mais s'ils ne sont pas
lourd les 90% des détritus dénombré
danses et continents sont inférieurs à 5
mm et c'est ce qu'on appelle les micro
plastiques
mais du coup tous viennent c'est si
nombreux petits débris aujourd'hui la
science pointe de sources majeures la
première ce sont les micro plastiques
primaire c'est-à-dire les micro
plastiques qui arrive dans l'océan
déjà sous forme de micro plastiques
certains ont été produits volontairement
avec une taille inférieure à 5 mm c'est
le cas des exfoliants dans les produits
cosmétiques et bien qu'interdit depuis
2018 on en trouvait encore dans les
stocks en 2009 et c'est pourquoi lors de
ma journée je me suis frotté les dents
avec des micro plastiques
d'autres sont les résidus des usages
c'est à dire les matériaux plastiques
qui sont dégradées et
et qui sont lessivés et le long des
routes par exemple c'est le cas des
pneus quelque chose de plus parlant
encore c'est les fibres textiles
synthétiques qui sont arrachés petit à
petit lors du lavage de notre vêtements
et que l'on retrouve dans les eaux usées
aujourd'hui il n'existe aucune
réglementation qui force les stations
d'épuration à enlever ces
microplastiques alors pour illustrer sa
ce week-end j'ai moi même mis les mains
dans le cambouis puisque j'ai ouvert le
fils de ma machine à laver et voilà ce
qu'on y trouve
et si on observe un petit peu saoul ou
binoculaire on obtient sa saison mais
cinq fois et on si on applique un petit
traitement de l'image pour séparer le
fond on voit distinctement plusieurs
particules qui se trouvaient dans ce
filtre alors on voit notamment des
microfibres qui elles se sont avérées
être synthétique et si vous ramenez donc
ça c'était 3 millilitres dans mon fils
de machines à laver et si vous ramener
ça à l'échelle d'une ville d'un
département ou une région imaginer la
quantité de petites particules qui
arrivent dans nos océans chaque jour bon
après les micro plastiques primaire
arrivent les micro plastiques secondaire
ce sont ceux qui sont issus de la
dégradation des gros déchets qui sont
déjà en mer sous l'action combinée de la
houle des embruns des ultraviolets et
même de certains organismes marins ces
déchets se fragmente en petite partie
qui reste et dérivent au gré des
courants dans nos océans et pourquoi ces
déchets ces gros déchets se retrouvent
dans nos océans ça la question
bon question simple mais réponses
complexes d'abord il faut savoir que 80
% d'entre eux sont d'origine terrestre
ce sont les déchets qui proviennent
directement des villes et qui se
déversent dans les rivières
ensuite les déchets qui proviennent des
eaux usées qui par exemple lors
d'intempéries en france les déversoirs
d'orage ont débordé mettre plein de
plastique ont ajouté dans nos
canalisations directement dans la
rivière
ensuite ce sont les produits industriels
et les déchets mal gérée lors de leur
fin de vie
ça peut ça prend ça peut prendre la fin
de décharges sauvages comme on l'a vu
dans mon premier en première partie de
ce dogme
donc ce sont les dg du aux plaisanciers
due au secteur de la pêche et de la
marine marchande qui sont parfois oblige
contraint d'abandonner du matériel ou
des cargaisons
bref nous sommes nous sommes tous en
agissant en allant à la mer en
consommant une source potentielle de
micro plastiques
le constat est fait nos océans et mers
sont cernées par les micros christique
mais quelles conséquences si les gros
déchets peuvent affecter directement les
animaux marins emblématiques comme les
oiseaux ou les tortues dans le cas avec
lesquels il risque de s'étouffer en
mangeant les micro plastiques ont un
effet beaucoup moins visible mais la
science avance et petit à petit on
essaie de trouver des réponses et 3
voire reviennent régulièrement
la première c'est que ces
microplastiques forme d'un nouvel
habitat il dérive souvent surface et
sont colonisées par des organismes plus
petits très mobile et très mobile ces
microplastiques et véhiculent ces
organismes qui arrivent dans des zones
où ils agissent comme des organismes des
espèces invasives ou pathogènes
inciviques est en 2017 a montré que le
micro plastiques joué un rôle important
dans le transport de la bactérie aéro
monasse salmonidés un fléau pour de
nombreuses espèces de poissons
salmonidés le deuxième problème c'est
l'ingestion par les animaux qui engendre
des problèmes physiques comme l'abrasion
des tubes digestifs
l'alimentation est bouleversé les
apports en énergie en pâtissent et cela
impacte la croissance et la survie des
poissons et crustacés qui les absorbe
enfin c'est un problème chimiques
puisque les plastiques en plus de
parfois originellement contenir des
additifs nocifs comme des comme des
perturbateurs endocriniens
ils ont la capacité d'absorber des
polluants organiques persistants les
molécules dangereuses se fixe dans les
micro plastiques qui les véhiculent
jusque dans les appareils digestifs des
espèces
la concentration de ces molécules
néfastes augmente à mesure que l'on
nomme que tout le monde dans la chaîne
alimentaire et cela représente
potentiellement un danger danger pour
l'homme car vous le savez sans doute
moins jean baucou de prédateurs marins
fasse un tel problème ce n'est pas trop
que de mettre à profit une partie de son
année de césure
pour lutter contre ce phénomène pour y
répondre
pertinemment l'association a depuis
trois ans trouvé quatre grands points
d'abord le premier et ville le premier
le plus évident c'est diminuer
drastiquement sa consommation de
plastique
facile me direz vous mais comme nous
avons vu à n'importe quelle journée et
potentiellement et maîtrise donc c'est
un défi quotidien
d'abord faire attention au choix de ses
vêtements je vous laisse essayer c'est
pas forcément évident moi même mes
chaussures ici sont composés de
plastique encore et je compte pas
forcément les changer demain
ensuite c est troqué ses produits
d'hygiène avec des produits 100 micro
billes sans emballage tant qu'à faire
c'est ça revient à long terme moins cher
mais c'est contraignant d'un premier
abord
ensuite c'est prendre le vélo les
transports en commun pour diminuer les
pneus qui à bras les particules de pneus
par kilomètre c'est à aller acheter en
vrac au supermarché etc etc
mais c'est une chance car c'est à la
portée de chacun d'entre nous moi même
qui suis d'ordinaire assez négligent
j'essaye et j'y arrive presque ça c'est
juste une chose il faut juste changer
ses habitudes
le second point lui est moins accessible
à tous il essaie d'optimiser de manière
générale la consommation des plastiques
dans la distribution de mettre en place
des mécanismes efficaces pour la gestion
de fin de vie des objets quotidiens et
favoriser en favorisant notamment
l'économie circulaire enfin un levier
efficace et l'augmentation des exigences
en termes de réglementation concernant
le traitement de l'eau les décharges
sauvages des interdictions de plastique
à usage unique
il faut se les mettre en place également
des mécanismes de suivi de ces
interdictions
bref message est plus difficile plus
difficile car modifier l'arsenal
législatif à l'échelle nationale ou
supranationales comme l'union européenne
modifie des paramètres économiques et
sociaux donc c'est assez difficile mais
pour cela chacun il faut que chacun de
nous s'engage derrière cette cause et ça
a déjà marché les interdictions pour les
plastiques à usage unique tombe peu à
peu en europe
les prises de conscience la prise de
conscience elle arrive lentement mais
sûrement on peut s'engager en tant que
consommateur ou en rejoignant
bénévolement des associations ou bien
même en parlant en en parlant autour de
soi au plus grand nombre
et c'est là la vocation la sauce
siplast x6 ordinaire c'est que ce type
d'engagement il est valable pour toutes
les causes que l'on redescend défendre
et en tant qu'étudiant césure il est
alors bon de s'interroger et se demander
pourquoi s'engager
comment bon laissez moi me confesser
avant de rejoindre 6 plastique c'était
je voulais rejoindre c'est honnêtement
pour la navigation la mer à voile
l'asthme est sympa mais à mesure de mon
implication dans l'association
j'ai compris combien s'engager pour une
cause même pour des raisons au départ
peut être futile faisait progresser tout
le monde par rapport à une problématique
donnée
et voilà comment mon engagement aux
côtés de 6 plastique s'est transformée
je me retrouve aujourd'hui à aider la
science en collaborant avec des
laboratoires ou organismes de recherche
comme le marbeck à montpellier mercator
océan ou université de barcelone avec et
pour lesquels nous produisons des
échantillons nous augmentons le nombre
de données exploitables pour des
publications scientifiques
nous testons des nouveaux protocoles
comme par exemple l'échantillonnage dans
la colonne d'eau qui permettent de
comprendre comment se répartissent les
différentes particules entre 0 et 100
mètres de profondeur en aidant la
science à mieux comprendre comment se
déplacent ces particules entre la
surface et les sédiments mais également
en donnant des informations sur les
origines de ces particules on évalue
objectivement et pragmatiquement ce
problème cela permet ensuite de trouver
des leviers d'action pertinents par
exemple si à l'embouchure d'un fleuve
l'on trouve une vaste majorité de micro
fibres textiles d'origine textile et
bien cela permet d'optimiser les choix
d'investissements en amont pour diminuer
de ces dites libres on est dans la
science nous prenons pas en plus à une
augmentation très significative de
l'intérêt de la recherche pour tous les
micro plastiques
quand on peut le voir sur l'évolution du
nombre de publications portent traitant
du sujet et depuis la création de
l'association en 2016 le nom de
publication a quadruplé
bon on le retrouve également à faire de
la sensibilisation
et d'ailleurs si je suis ici pour parler
je vous laisse deviner pourquoi c'est
pour révéler à tous que chacun est un
acteur et qu'en modifiant ses habitudes
il peut avoir un impact significatif sur
ce qu'ils souhaitent changer à cet effet
l'association
depuis trois ans rencontré une trentaine
d'écoles dont une quarantaine de stands
sur des porcs et réalisé une vingtaine
de conférences ces quelques milliers de
personnes rencontrées et voilà le
résultat
avec dix étudiants a peu motivé étalé
sur trois ans donc de manière générale
de nombreux projets voient le jour à
agroparistech et dans les milieux
étudiants et c'est une force car ces
étudiants font bouger les lignes sur de
très nombreuses problématiques tous les
étudiants s'engagent influence se
passionne pour un sujet et ils ont tous
ce point commun pendant un temps ils ont
un peu de temps ce que leur donne la
césure évidemment organisme expédia 36
mois ça prend du temps
ensuite il doit pour un bon médium dans
notre cas la voile véhicule un message
énergique en plus de nos interventions
un petit peu plus précise et les
scientifiques koster enfin tous tous les
étudiants ont une passion pour les
problématiques complexes dont ils
prennent une part de responsabilité pour
les faire évoluer
nous c'est les micro plastiques à leur
manière à notre manière j'invite tout le
monde à ne pas rester planté là a
constaté son impuissance face à des
problèmes que l'on voit je vous invite à
prendre conscience que chaque acte un
impact à plus grande échelle
je vous invite à vous engager pour des
causes qui vous sont plus chers moi ce
fut la mer
merci
[Applaudissements]